they said danny villeneuve will nerf
sure he wants to have a meeting with you
it's time to jump behind the scenes and
find out how dunes star-studded cast
came together working with denis and
this level of actors i learn so much
every day the latest remake of the
sci-fi epic led by timothy chalamet is
set to hit theaters and the core cast is
revealing how they got their parts from
smart networking to an impressive
audition by zendaya sometimes even the
director was the one tracking down
actors
she's tough right it probably won't come
as a surprise to anyone that when
superstar zendaya auditioned for the
part of johnny in dune director denis
vaneuve was absolutely blown away i
remember meeting johnny for the very
first time when zendaya made me believe
that she had been raised on an alien
planet in the deep desert in the
roughest environment however from
zendaya's perspective it wasn't quite as
exciting although she was equally
enthusiastic about working with denis
venue not a super crazy story i wish it
were more exciting when i found out that
it was being made i was extremely
interested i've always wanted to be part
of something sci-fi like that and i'm a
huge fan of denise i just went after it
and auditioned currently starring as mj
in the mcu spider-man movies alongside
tom holland zendaya jumped at the
opportunity to work with another rising
star in timothy chalamet we met at my
chemistry read i felt like we'd known
each other forever like this was my
homie growing up we became really great
friends you know if these were the
things that made me want to act when it
came to finding the lead for dune denis
venue made it clear that it was timothy
chalamet or no one we said it's timothy
chalamet we didn't have a plan b
honestly if he had said no i don't know
what i would have done there would be no
dune maybe coming off of standout roles
and call me by your name little women
the king and lady bird chalamet was
primed to jump into a big time
blockbuster and venue raved about how
perfect he was for the role of paul
atreides he's a real movie star he has
that insane charisma it also came as
little surprise that chalamet was just
as excited to be cast in the film just
to get the call was thrilling i'm still
pinching myself to hear denise say all
that it feels like i've pulled off the
heist of the century or i've fooled
someone completely and chalamet is all
in on a sequel as well
so huge gratitude for this whole process
i hope we get to make another one safe
to say all eyes will be on chalamet's
glowing blue ones in this movie hey you
put on some muscle i did
no
the magnetic jason mamoa was taken by
surprise when he received an unexpected
phone call from dune director denis
venue about starring in the movie but
what really moved him was that for the
first time in his career he didn't have
to audition i mean the moment he called
me he called me and he chose me i've had
to audition my whole life to get
something deniveneuve himself had plenty
to say about how he felt mamoa of
justice league aquaman and game of
thrones fame was ideal for the role of
duncan idaho boy mean relationship with
adventure and his elegance on screen and
jason mamoa is very aware of how much
this project means to denise he wanted
to do it his whole life it's his
masterpiece his life goal and for him to
look at me and see me as duncan idaho is
just crazy but you know when he called
after 10 minutes i was happy
mission impossible star rebecca ferguson
was actually a bit apprehensive when
denis venue approached her about joining
the dune cast but denise was too
stubborn to quit i didn't even listen
that's the thing
he completely didn't listen to it
ferguson's only real hang-up was that
she had played a queen before starring
as queen elizabeth in the miniseries the
white queen but lucky for us denise
managed to persuade her during a zoom
call pitching in his more nuanced
interpretation of the character denis
vaneuve shared his own thoughts on
ferguson's fit for the role of lady
jessica as well i needed an actress that
would be able to portray the different
layers very complex character to play
ladies jessica and ferguson's admiration
for denise is so high she'd be willing
to play as just about anything for him
at the same time i would be a teapot in
the background for denny i don't care
actor dave bautista was a big fan of not
only dune but also director denis venue
himself especially after working with
him in blade runner 2049 that's when i
started to really learn what a great
director denive anub was because he took
something and made it something you
weren't expecting so he was nearly moved
to tears when he received a surprise
phone call from denise offering him the
role of glossu rabon in dune i flipped
out i was almost in tears because this
is um like this was really what i fought
for like bautista also revealed that
he'd actually turned down other roles to
avoid getting typecasted and i passed up
on a lot of those roles because i wanted
to be offered roles like rabon in doom
so i knew with that one phone call that
i had made the right choices it
justified everything that i had done
dave is the sweetest human honored but
it's so frightening
actor david dismalchin known most
recently for his role in suicide squad
as polka dot man has actually been a
frequent collaborator of dune director
denis villeneuve appearing in both
prisoners and blade runner 2049. denis
called up dismulchin out of the blue to
offer him the role of piter devries and
it's safe to say dis mulchin was not
expecting to hear from him in fact he
initially thought the phone call was
from a mutual friend of theirs
i was like oh that's not sam that's
denis hey hey hi yes
being a big fan of the novel dissmalchen
was already familiar with his dune
character and was super excited about
what they were doing with the character
after reading the script the film script
that i read it honors and it brings to
life that book in such a beautiful way
i've never read anything like it there
is no call we do not answer there is no
faith that we betray actor oscar isaac
is definitely no stranger to science
fiction after starring in the academy
award-winning ex-machina and entering
the star wars universe as the rebel
leader poe dameron in the latest trilogy
it makes a lot of sense for denis
villeneuve to see isaac fitting right
into the world of dune not only that but
villeneuve was already a pretty big fan
of oscar one of the best actors
working to this when it comes to getting
in on a big hollywood blockbuster
sometimes it really is just about who
you know for actor chang chen a chance
meeting with denis villeneuve back in
2018 at the canes film festival paid off
big time when the director began looking
for the right person to take on the role
of dr wellington uwa we hit it off quite
well and one day i was invited by the
director to play a role in doom i
accepted immediately it was an easy
decision despite being one of the lesser
known cast members denis was quite
familiar with his work and had a lot of
praise to heap the panchen
damn deeply moved by his naturalism
despite being a former collaborator of
director denivel news most recently in
the thriller sicario villeneuve was not
the person that cast josh brolin in dune
after his time as thanos in the
record-smashing avengers films brolin
met with the production company
legendary to pitch a new project and
that meeting turned out better than he
could have ever imagined where she said
not only do i like the pitch i just
realized who should play uh gurney
howlick and dune despite such an
interesting casting story brolin has
opted to tell a different story from
interview to interview one time brolin
even claimed that he was cast for his
ability to play a unique instrument i've
been playing the ballast set actually
since i was seven which is why i was
hired for this actor stephen mckinley
henderson may not be the most
recognizable name but there's a decent
chance you've already seen his work his
notable recent credits include the
sci-fi mini-series devs and the
oscar-winning greta gerwig film lady
bird where he played the role of father
levich and director denivel new thought
he would be perfect in the role of
thuffer hawat i wanted an actor that
would have a lot of intelligence in the
eyes and at the same time would be like
a teddy bear when henderson got the call
from venue for the part he was surprised
to learn that this wasn't the first time
denis had wanted to work with him he
tried to get me for another movie
but i was busy and my managers never
even told me the first film adaptation
of dune hit theaters in 1984 and was
directed by legendary filmmaker david
lynch with denis villeneuve's dune
serving as the latest interpretation of
the landmark 1965 novel
how do you feel about remakes of older
films what's your opinion on david
lynch's polarizing adaptation let us
know in the comments